what are the coefficients let me just
pull these out right I'm going to say
see k plus 1 on see okay by the way i'll
just make a little note many text books
including the weather you mainly use
they don't actually use c4 coefficient
they use little tea I find that somewhat
maddening because then you've got
capital T per term and they choose
little tea which like is it's the same
letter and yd little tea when you've got
a perfectly good letter so I just don't
you to read out if you see the questions
and they keep on freezing in terms of
ability this is what they really mean
because the coefficients the
coefficients of the important part we're
not interested in the greatest term you
can't find out which one the greatest
term is because x is variable okay so
we're always looking at the coefficient
I just want to evaluate it first and
then I launch into the inequality okay
so let's have a go with this sorry
here's the one that's going to be on the
numerator okay so just step by step
let's pull out the numerical part of it
okay we already mentioned is going to be
this guy then you've got this guy I'm
now going to simplify it the way that i
renounce suggested okay doesn't matter
it then you've got this guy okay so
there's the coefficient of the k plus 1
term then on the denominator i'm going
to have this coefficient what i already
highlighted in green so it's going to
look like this
okay yes should it just be 32 k plus 1
i'll put it yep thank you pull out the
whole term okay now when you have a look
at this fraction admittedly it looks be
intimidating because you've got so many
things happening but this is kind of
like canceling heaven okay there are
going to be so many things that
disappear for instance there's the first
thing we already identified which is
that this one to the whatever and this
one to the whenever they just gone I
don't even need to think about those in
the same way just as really hopefully
pointed out you've got a some number of
threes here and then you've got also a
number of threes here exactly one less
exactly one less so what will happen is
you'll lose get a cup you'll lose all
these threes and what you'll get left
with is just one of the threes on the
top does that make sense now there's a
final bit of certification that's where
the most work is and that I have to go
back to remember what honor these things
are because there's going to be a lot of
cancelling easier to write so let's just
recall you might want to write up the
top you NCR generally speaking right
again it's a fraction what's on the top
n factorial on okay fantastic you may
like to jot that down it's on the
reference sheet but it's good enough to
have that out there because it's not
that hard to remember and you're going
to be using it a lot okay so because
what I've got here is going to be
fractions on fractions I'm going to sort
of break them apart I don't confuse
myself with my own right okay so first
let's do five see k plus 1 okay that's
going to be 5 factorial on k plus 1
factorial and this is going to be what's
this think about carefully
this number here is the same as this
number isn't it just is the same as that
number if you can't quite see it on the
air here is the five and then you're
subtracting k plus 1 right so that one
will bring out before so you're getting
this to grow that now rather like this I
can't Overby bakula MSA / this guy right
so this is 5 factorial on can you
factorial 5 minus K factorial so I'll
talk about this I've divided by this all
of these guys disappear and then you
multiply by 3 that's the three that's
left over how does it look so far making
sense okay good now have a look before i
do my flip fractions upside down like
kind of thing some of this is really
easy to work with for instance this 5
factorial on the numerator and this
other five factorial until the numerator
you divide through and they get so these
are gone that's nice yes like if I did
3/3 / cancel okay then left with these
guys okay look k plus 1 factorial
divided by K factorial well k plus 1
factorial is k plus 1 times K times K
minus mode hey where's to all the way
down I include all of these terms except
as an extra k plus 1 right does that
make sense so just be careful in the way
that you write this I'm going to ride on
the next line like this yeah okay I've
got remember this fracture it turns
upside down right so i'm going to write
that on the numerator now and then to
help us make sure we cancel this
properly i'm going to write you might
recall back in term one last year we
called this on unrolling the factorial
so it's got this extra term at the front
k plus 1 and then the rest of it is k
factorial okay k minus 1 chemistry etc
okay so there is that guy and then
lastly I cookies for my tour of all
multiple my three yeah i'm just not
finished yet that's like okay the reason
why i'm breaking apart i could do you
could see what i did here i can do here
as well and I
but students so frequently markup this
like they get the two things confused
with each other but I'm going to just do
them as two separate lines you don't
spend now much of your time so now i can
cancel this and this I'm find a way
you'll notice as much as I possibly can
I'm trying to circle things he rather
than crossing them out because as a
marker I still want to be able to read
what you're doing and no oh you can sort
something you recognize what it is a
very uncommon error that people met is
when they're doing this canceling they
skip this line let's get this line and
so they cancel k factorial and then they
canceled the ! just there and then they
miss Reed they were working and it's a
bit of a disaster okay it seems like a
silly thing to do because it isn't it
obvious but in the middle of an exam
when you're rushing it's not obvious
okay so i think it's worth writing this
extra line so that you can write out
exactly when you to cancel lastly I'm
going to do here I'll put that three on
the numerator back where it belongs this
guy I'm going to do the same unrolling
theme right so this is 5 minus K times 4
minus K times 3 minus K all the way down
so i'm going to write a five minus k out
the front the 4 minus K factorial which
is going to cancel in a second and this
is my ratio okay so last one the skies
will cancel and it lasts okay so this is
the ratio right that generally speaking
is what will generate these numbers down
here for me okay and now you can see I
putting it up I'm not going to get rid
of it because what do I want to do with
that right here I want to solve for when
it's greater than one but you should
tell me where in what region what part
of the via binomial coefficients an
extension will it continue to get bigger
and bigger ki go ahead and solve that
for me while I run this off find out
when that being is greater those on